[Music]
in doing them a favor news Oh God
submitted by chalkboard scratch watch
out for favors okay
because when you owe someone through
favors it's a surprise you don't know
what you got to do right spirits I
rather old money
[ __ ] pts you never know what you're
gonna ask you to [ __ ] when you get that
like April are you free I need a favor
no don't leave you say that they go Amy
are you free right now I'm right I don't
know maybe you know what it is depends
on what I gotta do my parents what do
you do right now I'm like I don't know
why what's up yeah a man spikes his
coworkers drinks with LSD to fix their
negative energy so micro dose I heard
about that with E I heard that oh wait
no it was Alice Steve micro dosing is
like in right now yes the upgrades the
way you think I've never done it either
it's jobs Steve Jobs said that he
doesn't trust anybody that's never done
LSD I've done LSD you know what and I
liked it so much I was so scared I'm
like [ __ ] I should never talk and we
never did it she was let's go group trip
we'll all go trip woods yeah yeah good
with sound back oh that dude yeah I just
I know somebody who knows somebody hmm
know somebody but that person did acid
recently unlike this that you know that
whole I [ __ ] go into the forest type
of [ __ ] out in my Portland and stuff
yeah came back all [ __ ] up forever
forever and lock some weird-ass [ __ ]
yeah you could unlock a door that she
that's what I'm too scared of I'm scared
of too cuz I'm [ __ ] weird enough as it
is
mmm-hmm like with her she was completely
level whatever broke up with her
boyfriend he doesn't do drugs often does
she she does no but whatever that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] [ __ ] her up edibles can do
that to you my friend's brother went
[ __ ] crazy after it taking too many
edibles
like even like Joe Rogan he's hyper like
we'd like he's very for it but he's like
it's not for everybody it just depends
cuz like he knows personal friends who
like smoke this [ __ ] and they haven't
been the same [ __ ] some [ __ ] up in there
if you have schizophrenia and your
family or any sort of psychosis you
could have a dormant gene and ate like
unlock some [ __ ] oh it's crazy a lot of
drugs did too much I'm trying to unlock
nothing in here dude
I'm Trustee stupid well I'm trying to
unlock another galaxy you should do DMC
then that's true but if you give it if
someone spikes your [ __ ] you don't even
know it's happened he's like [ __ ] you
sad here drink this
I'm sick and tired of your [ __ ]
attitude how you feeling now whatever it
does it enhances the mind to think that
you're in now or whatever subconscious
is it hallucinogenic oh hell yeah so
here at thanks Geo
this happened at an enterprise
rent-a-car listen listen I got a rhino
in the back right now and we saw what
colors the cars there were some workers
that were taken to a hospital they were
24 and 23 years old people yeah a 27
year old manager of the rental car place
called the police she reported that one
of her 19 year old employees was acting
weird and she saw him allegedly holding
a dropper and messing with her water
drop jug that was in the police report
she also told the officers that she saw
him doing the same thing with some of
the other employees water and then those
employees later became very dizzy and
were like real falling in and out of
consciousness
oh they're just drugging everybody yeah
why wait for free he says they were too
uptight and they needed to have better
energy oh god that worked yeah and he
has not been this [ __ ] work he has not
been charged yet but he faces the
possible charges of second-degree
assault and possession of a controlled
substance oh for sure yeah yeah hospital
is gonna happen he's [ __ ] up he should
have used weed that he could I just use
[ __ ] like THC [ __ ] [ __ ] or
whatever see me
you see BB drops or something cookies
and passes it out or something or just
get another job or maybe energy strip by
yourself everything else is good yeah
and everybody would be great yeah I
didn't like their trippin with that kind
of cool maybe he was already tripping
and he's like I don't like their energy
but there are some people that see you
can't drug nobody right but there's
people that don't see it that way so I
can speak from firsthand experience we
had someone at our gym that would bring
drugs and then they'd fall out and then
we had a talent like hey dude don't ever
bring that again this is grounds to
getting fired it happened again a few
weeks later but they were shrooms this
time and we were like I didn't bring we
yeah we I thought we told you you can't
bring drugs to work he was like oh these
aren't drugs these are shrooms they're
organic
oh you're [ __ ] dumb is [ __ ] you dumb
marijuana yeah so so people think like
that did you get fired
crack geo I know what dude alcohol is
legal but you can't be getting drunken
yeah what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you dumb [ __ ] yeah this person really
buff because I hope they don't find me
it's not drugs it's just vicodin yeah
there's some people that just miss like
in substance yeah they can't charge this
guy at all until the lab results come
back and for LSD yeah I confirm
everything but they are pretty sure that
it's LSD openly admitted said hey they
needed to relax so I [ __ ] their stuff to
himself
I know he's got issues you can't be
doing that or on and it's gotta be fun
it could be fun they must have been a
fun day at work though watching
everybody she got people driving [ __ ]
Enterprise cars around and passionately
bringing yeah it's real tight it's like
those real tight [ __ ] Apartments
should we do that in our company and
like should you like a Russian Roulette
so you have like seven drinks and then
one spikes with something and everyone
else like oh you're just not you just do
gotta be out of nowhere though you could
drug everybody and then is it today you
should hold episode and you just watch
it later on like whoa I feel like Joe
does that to his own drinks every day
then because I would not be able to tell
the difference he's
playing random instruments for like my
guess I didn't get it I'm more normal on
drugs
yeah really you go the opposite you
start doing your taxes I start like
being a responsible human beings our
leader like he's not our leader but he's
like are like supervisor like he'll like
Andre I'm like we're all high right now
but I still have a silver mine so let's
go and everyone's like at a field trip
and I'm like we're going this way come
on that's who I was but I didn't do the
drugs I was always the sober one yeah
cuz people could trust you yeah but for
me I feel like oh [ __ ] I'm high as [ __ ]
but I'm like Indiana Jones right now and
I'm the only one that can see the future
come on guys you guys are too [ __ ]
high come on you [ __ ] high asses
we're going this way he's talking
through the wall you see the future
there um yeah I got way too paranoid off
of marijuana like had totally bad trips
everything would be like flashy like
this and then I look in the mirror not
recognize myself and I'd start crying
and then I thought my tongue was gonna
get swallowed and my kitchen was just
bad on marijuana so then when people
were doing shrooms or acid or whatever
I'm like I'm not touching that because
I'm I can't even handle weed
so I'll just babysit you all and it was
really funny it was like oh you're
control freak yeah what about alcohol do
you trip out on alcohol no that relaxes
me that's like the one thing I'm such a
happy drunk I just go around giving
people hugs and I like to dance and I
just feel good and I'm not thinking
about everything you might like Mara I
think things I should do some meth no no
don't do [ __ ] drug Rolodex he's like
like he's a doctor with the white with
the white sauce oh so benadryl didn't
work you might like okay cuz needs a
downer
okay hallucinogens just scared of that
you might like a upper because alcohol
mmm oh that's a depressant though
alcohols are depressing yeah
yeah but it doesn't depress me I'm miss
makes no it doesn't depress me at all
yeah Sheila has Cathy this akela takes
you up yeah tequila's really organic if
you're on a diet you could drink tequila
tequila to turn I just can't get over
the taste in the smell oh you have two
good tequila tequila you have all of
alcohol to me I'm like it just it's like
filtered multiple times it tastes like
water
yeah cuz I don't like liquor either but
like a really good tequila yeah I didn't
like it for a long time but now you just
been [ __ ] up in the past
you don't feel that way about crack meth
[ __ ] weed it's just the first thing
if there's no what is it your throat and
you're like oh I'm gonna die that's
smoke well yeah you coughing ah but when
you smell we you're paranoid just
smelling weed though Oh was that it
someone baking something Oh what is that
oh I don't like this smells like [ __ ]
you know this mother [ __ ] love drugs
deadly do you talk about drugs like the
way I talk about big dolls hash browns
don't do it anymore though see ya the
memory of it good self-control that's
why I did so you ever just have a crack
rock you just do this just a couple of
yeah that's true there's no flavor to
LSD it just melts in your mouth
there's no consequences you know after
Jason lets Jim's I heard tastes like
[ __ ] I never ate and you get bubble guts
have you ever true to evil it's bitter
you shouldn't chew pills any pills why
hit you way harder so I would chew the
[ __ ] goes away fast but it is very very
bitter cocaine is the nasty one
see I never did that ever tried any of
it it is disgusting marijuana and
alcohol which are legal in California
now so try and get me oh [ __ ] you it's
Johnny goals government control or what
you putting your [ __ ] body unless it
in do you want to die who cares that's
what was happening with cocaine as if
people were going [ __ ] crazy
ok ok I agree I agree because I forgot
about the people that's like a
controller so they start stealing and
yeah yeah cuz there's a lot of
crackheads white groups cocaine and
violence have like a shared alcohol
though right - yeah yes yes oh yeah they
tried to make it away because alcoholics
they beat that why was illegal yeah they
drink prohibition [ __ ] but the hard part
was it was already legal and then they
tried to make it illegal and you can't
break the toothpaste back in the tube
yeah but you never seen the aged person
I can do it they can put toothpaste back
you just suck on a toothpaste and you
spit it inside a tube I'm not like that
[Music]